so in this video I'm going to answer a
question relating to not having a
thyroid someone wanted to know my
opinion and if there's any long-term
complications etc first thing I want to
say is that I'm not giving you medical
advice this is not gonna bypass your
what you're already taking now check
with your doctor before implementing any
of this and this is just for your own
research okay
now over the years I've had quite a few
people come into my office after having
a thyroidectomy and they did just fine
so out of all the things that could
happen to a person and all the potential
organs that you can have removed I think
having thyroid out and being on a
certain hormone protocol you could do
quite fine okay so the thyroid is
ultimately controlled by the
hypothalamus in the brain it's a very
small structure it makes a hormone
called thyroid releasing hormone and
this gland tells this gland the
pituitary to release thyroid stimulating
hormone and then that message goes to
the thyroid and causes the thyroid to
produce and release t4 and a little bit
of t3 okay t4 is an inactive thyroid
hormone t3 is the active version and
what happens is for this to work it has
to be converted into t3
so it actually works through several
organs to being the liver and the
kidneys 80% of the t4 is converted to
the liver 20% is converted to the kidney
to make t3 and then t3 goes into all the
cells and affects metabolism and many
other things and once it's done its job
there's a signal that's sent back to the
pituitary and hypothalamus turning these
off okay so you have a feedback loop now
what a person has their thyroid removed
there are three points that I think we
should emphasize one is you also have
something called a parathyroid gland
that's right next to the thyroid and you
want to make sure that they don't take
those out as well okay so you want these
left intact because the parathyroid
gland control
calcium and many other things but
they're very important glands there's
four of them okay that's one the second
point I want to bring up is something
called calcitonin very few people are
talking about calcitonin there's not a
strong emphasis on this hormone and
because what happens is once you have
the thyroid removed typically you're put
on a synthetic t4 like centroid which
doesn't have this in there okay so the
question is where are you getting this
from well let's talk about what it does
it inhibits osteoclasts what does that
mean well osteoclasts break down bone
okay so this hormone slows down that
process so it actually helps
osteoporosis or prevents it and there's
even a therapy called salmon calcitonin
used for postmenopausal osteoporosis
okay interesting and also it's used for
spinal stenosis which is basically the
space around the spinal column is
smaller because there's a calcium
buildup so apparently calcitonin helps
this condition right here so my question
is where are you getting this okay and
are they leaving the parathyroids now
one way to get this is by taking a
complete thyroid extract complex which
is it's called armored thyroid you can
check with your doctor on this a lot of
doctors don't like to use it because
it's hard to regulate they like to use
just the t4 but I think it's really
important to bring this up to your
doctor and also ask the big question
where am I getting my calcitonin okay
because when you're taking a synthetic
version of t4 you're not getting
calcitonin so that being said once this
gland is removed and you're on your
hormones okay and everything's being
adjusted I don't think there's anything
that you should do that's special or
different other than getting on your
healthy keto and in a minute fasting
thanks for watching
if you're liking this content please
subscribe now and I will actually keep
you updated on future videos